أنا مهتم بشكل خاص بالحصول على
رد فعلك على آخر شيء السيد.  باو ،
الذي قال إنه إذا كان هذا الدعم لإسرائيل ، وإذا كان هذا الدعم لإسرائيل
كما وضعه وهو ينطلق من
جرف حل الدولتين ، فإن
ذلك يضر إسرائيل ، فكيف
تشرح كيف ترد على ذلك
لا أعتقد أن أي شخص مسؤول في ذلك؟
تدفع إسرائيل باتجاه حل الدولة
الواحدة ، لذا أعتقد أن مخاوفه
هي أنك تعلم أنني أفهم وجهة نظره ولكن
لا أعتقد أن هناك بالفعل
حركة سياسية جادة في إسرائيل من أجل
حل الدولة الواحدة ولا أعتقد ذلك
من الأفعال الواقعية
التي اتخذناها خلال العامين الماضيين
يقودنا إلى هذه النقطة ، لا بأس ،
أنا أفهم ، آسف أننا مضطرون للتأجيل ،
آسف لمقاطعتك ، أنت تقول
إن إدارة ترامب و  لا تزال
خطة كوشنر للسلام
ومشاركتك فيها
تؤمن وتدعم فكرة
حل الدولتين ولكن عندما
لا نستخدم هذه العبارة ولكن ليس
لأننا نحاول التوجه نحو حل الدولة
الواحدة ، فإن القضية التي لدينا  يوافق
مقدما  إلى دولة لأن كلمة
دولة تستحضر معها
الكثير من القضايا المحتملة التي نعتقد
أنها تضر بنا لاستخدام هذه
العبارة حتى نتمكن من الحصول على
عرض كامل لجميع الحقوق
التي ستدخل في
فلسطين.  نحن نؤمن
بالحكم الذاتي الفلسطيني ، ونؤمن
بالحكم الذاتي المدني الفلسطيني ،
ونعتقد أن هذا الحكم الذاتي يجب أن
يمتد حتى النقطة التي
يتدخل فيها مع الأمن الإسرائيلي
وهي إبرة معقدة للغاية